la georgie va recompter car moins d'un
demi point de pourcentage séparent les
deux candidats dans les autres états
très disputée aujourd'hui c'est
automatique en arizona et en
pennsylvanie est possible dans le nevada
et en caroline du nord
dans chacun de ces états ces vingt
dernières années lorsqu'il y a eu au
comptage le vainqueur n'a jamais changé
en 2016 oui ce concert trois millions et
demi de dollars ont été dépensés pour
tout raconter
donald trump en est ressorti avec
seulement cent trente et une voie
supplémentaire pour la directrice des
élections et chaude ça a démontré la
précision du système
en fait depuis 2000 sur quelque 30
recomptage dans les états
le résultat final n'a varié en moyenne
que de 0,0 19 % dans certains états
comme le michigan un nouveau
dépouillement peut être exigée avec des
preuves de fraudes
ils essaient de fraude et aucun doute
dans l'esprit de donald trump ni de son
fils qui a tweeté cette image montrant
soit disant des bulletins a mené au
milieu de la nuit dans un chariot à
detroit l'homme en question c'était lui
un photographe qui transportait des
batteries déjà après sa victoire contre
hillary clinton
il prétendait que des fraudes lui avait
fait perdre le vote populaire de près de
3 millions de voix seul devant la
commission qu'il a mise sur pied pour
faire la lumière a été dissoute sans
avoir pu établir la moindre fraude
quant à la floride en 2000 bush mené
avec près de 1800 voit le soir des
élections
il l'a finalement emporté grâce à 537
vote quand la cour suprême a mis fin au
recomptage
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal